Pyeongchang has been consistently building winter sports facilities...
...and nurturing young athletes like Yu-na to achieve their best,...
...all with the single goal in mind:...
...to host an Olympic and Paralympic Winter Games.
"New Horizons" has a simple goal:...
...to give young Koreans and young athletes access to world-class sports facilities for the first time,...
..the same chance that I was fortunate to receive in America.
That's what this bid is all about:...
...it's about hope.
So you may ask yourself,...
..."To whom are we listening to today?"
"To Toby Dawson, the American olympian..."
"...or to Kim Bong-seok, the little Korean boy with the ability to be an Olympian..."
"...with limited resources to do so?"
Well to be honest, you're listening to both.
I came here today to achieve two things.
First, I want to honor my home country and its people, my people.
I want to return some small measure,...
...the good fortune that I received in life from sport.
And second, I want to speak for future generations in Korea and beyond.
I ask you to give them the same chance...
...that I was so fortunate to receive in America in 1981:...
...the chance to participate, the chance to excel, and the chance to succeed.
Your support today of Pyeongchang 2018...
...would truly change the lives of millions of kids...
...who haven't had the opportunity to be an Olympian.
I believe that there is no greater honor...
...than representing one's country at the Olympic Games.
It is my dream that every child...
...everywhere in the world can hope for that possibility.
Thank you members of the IOC for all that you do every day...
...to make dreams come true.
And thank you for the promise of hope that the Olympic values provide to us all.